as it turns out 45 years you have a
daughter that you don't know about yeah
you heard that right
duck dynasty patriarch 74 year old Phil
Robertson just found out he has a 45
year old daughter named Phyllis let's
rewind shall we
during the latest episode of his
unashamed podcast
the reality star was joined by the four
sons he shares with his wife Kay I'll
chase Jeff and Willy they revealed they
first learned about Phyllis when she
wrote a letter to Alan Jace claiming to
be their sister so basically it was from
a woman who said that by a DNA search
she thinks that Dad might be her dad al
said at first they dismiss the whole
thing but eventually realized it might
be legit well once we get into that
let's start looking a little more deeply
I'm like oh whoa whoa this isn't just
and you're like all right yeah I mean
that might be something to this and I
started thinking about it I thought this
is there's a 45 year old woman out there
that doesn't know who her dad is
and she's looking and I thought even if
it's not dad she needs to know it's not
that so after giving it a lot of thought
al said he decided to tell his rents
about the letter and Phil agreed to take
a DNA test which ended up being a 99%
match the 74 year-old said he wanted to
meet his daughter and he did and he even
promised that duck dynasty fans will get
to meet her soon enough to adding that
they plan to have her on the podcast as
a special guest it's a pretty cool
explanation of redemption reconciliation
love it's as it turns out forty-five
years you have a daughter that you don't
know about and she has a father she
doesn't know about so finally after all
those years
come together and honestly everyone
seems pretty damn happy about the whole
thing yeah it was super awesome I was so
excited it was like to me like a dream
come true
our marriage is living proof the lovin
family can get you through anything the
family's reality series duck dynasty was
cancelled back in 2016 but one family
member who isn't ruling out a return to
reality TV Willy's daughter Sadie
Robertson I'm not gonna say never cuz
like we would have never thought we
would have it to be show in the first
place when et caught up with the 22 year
olds who married Christian Hough in
November she said she might be down it
was crazy but maybe maybe one day
everything's change though you know now
I'm married John Luke and Mary Kate have
a baby my other sister had it we grew
three family members this year like so
much life has happened that if we did it
it would look so different I don't know
and I think right now because we all
live in different places it would be
hard to have that element that made guys
what it is so once we're all back in the
same place who knows maybe we'll do a
little family show